[Music]
when every other voice is hushed and in
quietness we wait before him the Silence
of the Soul makes more distinct the
voice of God welcome to Q&A with elder
Randy SK on the word inspired I am your
host Denisha mcin and today we are
discussing repentance
before we go any further let's have a
word of
prayer Lord we absolutely need you now
especially with the technical
difficulties Lord we know this is a word
that people need to hear we need to hear
and the enemy is trying to construct
blockades for allowing your word to be
freely spread but I pray God that you
would be with us forgive us of our sins
anoint your man servant give him a
double portion even Sevenfold rather of
your spirit right now dear Lord so that
as he speaks that we will know how to
turn away from our sins because the
words will be coming straight from you I
thank you for hearing and for answering
this prayer in Jesus's name amen
amen all right so our special guest
today is none other than Elder Randy SK
if there was a word I could use to
describe him it would be consistent yes
faithful religiously he disseminates the
word of God every Friday afternoon he's
always answering the call to spread the
gospel in various countries various
States even if it may not be expedient
for him personally he is a loving man of
God he's faithful and he is willing to
be used completely by God's spirit so as
he is here today I pray that you'd ask
God to put his words in his mouth and
also continue to pray than
and be Reverend as he speaks I welcome
Elder Randy SK thank you very much my
dear sister Dr Denisha it's always a
singular pleasure a holy privilege to be
a part of your program I mean that with
concentrated seriousness I think it's a
blessed service that you do under God's
Direction and thank you for frequently
allowing me to be a part of it and I
pray that God will tell me what to say
that those who listen for whom Christ
shed his blood might be blessed and
their lives improved spiritually thank
you very much amen thank you I'm sorry
I'm like overcoming this cold so my
voice is kind of going okay all right so
let's get to the first question which
has two parts the first is what is
repentance and the second is what is its
role in
Salvation so uh repentance is a very uh
simple concept to Define it is simply
turning away from it's different from uh
confession confession means I admit I
have done wrong I admit that that's fine
we need repentance are turning away from
and so that's what repentance is if
you're a thief you come to Christ I'm
sorry he expects you to turn away from a
life of theft Ela white tells us in the
Desire of Ages page 555 paragraph 6
genuine repentance leads to Reformation
a change in life and one evidence of
true repentance is indeed a change in
one's Behavior its role in Salvation
without repentance there cannot be
salvation the angel told Joseph she
shall bring forth a son Matthew 1:21
Thou shalt call his name Jesus where he
shall save his people from their sins a
repentant person wants to be saved from
his or her sins without repentance that
person wants to be saved in his or her
sins but there must be repentance God
saves us from and so we live a different
life we go from flesh to Spirit our
thoughts our words our actions must be
different repentance is turning away
from without that repentance they cannot
be
salvation they can be church membership
they can be Outreach they can be all
sorts of things but not
salvation profound you know it's amazing
Jesus came to save us but he cannot save
us if we choose to hold on to the
to save us from that's right so thank
you for making that plain so now that
we've understood what repentance is and
the importance of it in our soul
salvation who puts in the heart the
desire to
repent and should we repent before we
come to Christ I mean what are the steps
to repentance all right uh you don't
repent before you come to Christ because
the urge to repent is from Christ in uh
acts chap 5:3 and 31 the Bible says God
of our fathers raised up Jesus whom he
slew and hanged on a tree him hath God
exalted with his right hand to be a
prince and a savior for to give
repentance to Israel and forgiveness of
sins it is God that puts it on the heart
for a person to repent 2 Timothy
2:2 in meekness instructing those that
oppose themselves if God per Adventure
will give them repentance to the
acknowledge of the truth Romans chap 2:4
or despises thou The Riches of his
goodness not knowing that the goodness
of the Lord leadth thee to repentance
and so Romans 2:4 tells us God's
goodness God's goodness leads us to
repentance 2 Timothy chapter 2:25 God
gives us repentance acts 5:31 God gives
us repentance it is impossible to repent
unless Christ puts that impulse within
us and so repentance requires the work
of God and so we come to Christ before
we repent and we repent in the presence
of Jesus
Christ amen in other words you don't try
to fix yourselves and then come to
Christ that's Christ's word you come to
him as you are broken sinful bad
whatever the adjective may be and you
ask him to put you right what of the
things he does he puts the impulse
within to repent El tells us in uh steps
to Christ P 26 paragraph 3
Christ is the source of every right
impulse and the impulse to repent is a
right impulse it is not a product of the
carnal nature and so to repent Christ
has to do a work in that person and so
the person comes to Christ in his
corrupt condition or her condition and
then Christ works on the person and one
of the things he does is to put into
that person the urge the desire to
repent that conviction that comes from
the spirit but you don't make yourself
right and then come to God you can't do
that you must come to him and let him
initiate the work of transformation
which includes repentance under the
impulse of the holy spirit amen amen
thank you for you know delineating those
steps so we must come to Jesus allow
Jesus to put in our hearts that desire
to repent through with the convictions
of
Christ amen amen thank you so much A lot
of people think they're too bad or too
evil to come to Christ that's a mistake
Christ came to save to the uttermost or
some people like to say from the
uttermost to the uttermost you come to
him as you are drunk with a with the
liquor bottle in your pocket the drugs
in your pocket whatever you come that
way and you say I want my life
changed and if you mean it Christ will
begin the
process that's why he died that thief on
the cross he said to Christ he
recognized who Christ was he became
converted he acknowledged Christ
accepted Christ and was saved and we'll
see him in the
Kingdom amen amen
amen all right so I will ask the next
question and this question is inspired
by 2 Corinthians chapter 7 verse 10 I'm
going to quickly read it there as Paul
about the letter he wrote to the
Corinthians and what it do
says for Godly sorrow worketh repentance
to
Salvation not to be
repented the sorrow of the world worketh
death so this question El is yes what
role does guilt play in
Repentance the thing about Sin is guilt
guilt is thing that kills us I'm sure if
you speak to most therapists they'll
tell you the reason people come to see
them is they struggling with guilt it is
a major contributor to the reasons why
people go to see therapists and
psychologists and whoever else
psychiatrists guilt Christ took that
guilt upon him when he took our sins and
so guilt you say what's the role of
guilt guilt does not play a role in
Salvation guilt contributes to our
spiritual misery Christ removes the
guilt when you confess your sins and he
forgives you he removes the sin he
removes the guilt is really the guilt
that causes all the problem a person can
sin ignorantly and not experience guilt
because he or she does not know of the
sin because of ignorance so guilt is
what one feels when one is aware of
having done wrong and Christ removes
that along with forgiveness of sins he
took on him our guilt the thing that
crushes us and kills us and so guilt
plays no role in Salvation guilt has to
be removed when Christ forgives and
takes our sins upon
himself amen amen amen thank you for
breaking that down Elder SK I'm now
going to invite let me say this let me
say this sorry feeling
guilty may drive someone to Christ yes
yes that doesn't mean it plays a role
really but a sense of a lot of people
feel guilty and do nothing about it they
just silence the conviction some people
when they feel that guilt they they they
have that that spiritual decency to come
to Christ so he can do something about
it that's as far as I go in saying that
guilt has any role in Salvation a sense
of guilt may drive someone to
Christ if the person's
honest yes we must see our need we must
see our need absolutely yes so I'm now
going to transition allow brother
Jonathan Archie that's next three
questions yes so uh the following
question that I have for you Elder SK is
yes you know in in you know actually did
the message on this on the life of Judas
um in Matthew
27:3 um you know we we hear what takes
place after um you know he he comes and
speaks with the officials in the temple
and of course receives the money and
Matthew 27:3 it says then Judas which
had betrayed him when he saw that he was
condemned repented himself and brought
again the 30 pieces of silver to the
chief priest and Elder and so the
question is uh would you consider this
Godly repentance or true repentance um
as before it cannot be Godly repentance
because here's what Jesus said of Judas
in John
17:12 those that thou gavest me I have
kept and none of them is lost but the
son of predition Jesus said Judas is
lost he was sorry because things did not
work out out the way he intended he had
hoped Christ would release himself
Christ did not judas's repentance
was genuine repentance that leads to
Salvation And so no his repentance was
not the kind that leads to Salvation and
uh a right relationship with God he was
sorry because he was caught and things
did not work out a lot of people are
sorry because they are caught they're
not sorry because of the horrible nature
of what they did they're sorry because
they've been exposed M that's all and
that was judas's
condition Jesus said he's lost mhm I
hear you on that and we find one of the
other disciples uh I would believe after
he had been caught so I asked you this
question uh with Peter you know he he he
was caught in in his lie of denying
Christ three times and it says that he
had run off and you know he started uh
crying and things like that so how would
you uh contrast uh his repentance versus
Judas well the life of of Peter after
that event clearly tells us his
repentance was genuine he was sorry for
what he had done you know when Christ
looked at him after he denied him three
times El says it broke his heart he went
he cried he cried because he felt he
realized he was wrong to deny his savior
his repentance was genuine and he went
on to become the second greatest Apostle
after Paul and so there's a world of
difference between judas's sorrow and
Peter's sorrow Judas was sorry because
things did not work out Peter was sorry
because he realized he was wrong and his
conscience was bothered and he repented
that's why Christ asked him three times
lovest thou me lovest thou me because he
denied Christ three times he had to
reaffirm his love three times three
times
okay that's deep